Trascrizione: Martina Margoni
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Essere a Trento è come essere a Hollywood!
Incredibile!
(Risate)
Pensate di essere stati influenzati
dai cartoni animati,
cioè dai film di animazione
che avete visto da bambini?
Avete mai sognato di essere
un super eroe invincibile,
una fata affascinante,
o un mago esuberante?
O forse di volare
verso l'isola che non c'è?
Provate ad immaginare.
E se potessimo usare l'animazione,
non solo per permettere ai bambini
di tuffarsi in mondi
incredibili e fantastici,
ma anche per trasportarli
in mondi reali, diversi dai loro.
Mondi che a volte possono incutere
timore o anche paure.
Paure, si!
Paura del diverso,
del cambiamento, paura dell'ignoto.
E se con la magia dell'animazione
potessimo sconfiggere queste paure?
Avvicinare così le culture e superare
le barriere delle diversità culturali.
Probabilmente state pensando
che io sia una pazza visionaria.
Ma torniamo bambini,
solo per un attimo.
Chiudete gli occhi,
per piacere, solo per un secondo.
Pensate al vostro primo cartone animato.
Andate indietro con la memoria.
Qual era quel film?
Quanto vi ha emozionati
e quanto vi ha coinvolti?
Io penso che in questo momento abbiate
un'idea molto vivida di un'immagine.
E penso che sia una memoria collegata
ad un periodo dei vostri primi dieci anni.
Si ritiene, infatti,
che i primi dieci anni siano fondamentali
per la formazione di un individuo.
Quello che vivete,
ma soprattutto quello che provate,
le emozioni durante questo periodo,
vi segnano, ve le portate
dentro tutta la vita.
E allora mi sono detta:
"Ma se si potesse andare
al di là della storia della principessa
che bacia una rana,
del coyote che segue un uccello,
o della fata dei desideri?
Se si potesse, con l'animazione,
parlare anche di "storie diverse".
Potremmo, così, influenzare i bambini
prima dei loro dieci anni,
prima che siano completamente
formati come individui.
E potremmo portare loro messaggi
di coraggio, di cambiamento
e forti valori morali e culturali.
C'era una volta un bambino siriano,
che sognava di essere
ballerino nel suo Paese,
ma, forzato dalla guerra,
è stato costretto a realizzare
il suo sogno altrove.
C'era una volta una bambina afghana,
innamorata della musica,
e, contro ogni opinione, è riuscita
non solo a diventare musicista,
ma anche a diventare la direttrice
della prima orchestra afghana
composta da sole donne.
C'era una volta un bambino del Malawi,
che grazie alle sue invenzioni
riesce a portare l'elettricità,
per la prima volta,
nel suo villaggio sperduto.
Insomma, storie importanti,
storie di piccoli grandi eroi
che devono essere raccontate.
Devono essere portate ai nostri figli,
e perché no,
con la magia dell'animazione.
E qui lasciatemi raccontare
una storia, la mia.
Come molti di voi nel pubblico,
sicuramente,
siete cresciuti con storie di guerra.
Mia nonna era una bambina
nella Prima Guerra Mondiale.
Mia mamma, poi,
sopravvisse alla Seconda.
Di tutte le storie
che mia mamma mi ha raccontato,
quella che più mi ha segnato,
che più mi è rimasta dentro,
è quella in cui mi descriveva
come si sentiva da bambina
sotto i bombardamenti,
proprio qui a Trento.
Una bambina senza forza,
bloccata dalla paura,
che non riusciva a scappare.
Mia mamma, più che una storia,
è riuscita a farmi capire
come un bambino si possa sentire
nel mezzo di un conflitto,
è riuscita a trasmettermi
quel suo indelebile ricordo: un'angoscia.
Un'angoscia che forse possiamo cercare
di capire, guardando foto come questa.
Noi sappiamo bene, purtroppo,
che questa non è la prima
e non sarà nemmeno l'ultima.
E se non si fa qualcosa,
se non ci impegniamo,
la storia continua a ripetersi.
E infatti, quando avevo 20 anni
ed ero al mio primo corso di animazione,
scoppiò la guerra nei Balcani.
E in quel momento, tutte le storie
raccontatemi da mia mamma,
che erano rimaste nel mio cuore
e nella mia mente,
non erano più così lontane.
E in quel momento decisi e mi ripromisi,
che quando mi sarei sentita pronta,
avrei usato l'arte, che adoro e che amo,
l'animazione,
per agire e cercare
di fare una differenza.
E dopo anni passati nel mondo
dell'animazione internazionale,
capii che ero pronta per scrivere
e dirigere il mio primo film.
Sapevo esattamente
di cosa avrei voluto parlare.
C'era una volta una bambina a Trento,
sotto i bombardamenti;
si chiamava Mila.
Mi rivolsi con entusiasmo
a tutti gli studi, i grandi studi,
ma ben presto capii
che questi studi non erano interessati
a parlare di storie socialmente impegnate.
Queste storie non erano
"adatte" al loro business
e nessuno voleva investire
in un cartone animato
che parlasse di guerra.
Fu una pillola difficile da digerire,
ma, come forse sapete, tante volte
dal rifiuto può nascere la forza.
E così decisi di non accettare quel "no".
E allora mi rivolsi
ai miei amici e colleghi
e la loro risposta fu incredibile.
Il desiderio di mettere in evidenza
la tragedia dei bambini vittime di guerra,
ma non solo, di parlare
in generale di temi forti,
con un linguaggio dolce
e più accessibile ai bambini,
ci ha uniti.
Ed oggi il "Mila team"
conta più di 350 artisti
che collaborano volontariamente
da trentacinque Paesi,
alcuni dei quali, purtroppo,
nel mezzo di conflitti.
E questo è un esempio del nostro lavoro.
(Video)
Come vi è sembrato?
Troppo forte per i bambini?
Io penso di no.
Io penso che, purtroppo,
sottostimiamo i bambini.
I bambini hanno
una mente curiosa,
hanno la mente aperta,
sono liberi da pregiudizi
e riescono così a processare le cose
in modo diverso da noi.
Questa meravigliosa forma d'arte,
l'animazione,
è stata purtroppo limitata e inscatolata
in un genere cinematografico.
Ed è ora di aprire questa scatola
e permettere ai registi,
agli artisti, agli storyteller,
di portare al grande pubblico
anche un altro tipo di animazione.
L'animazione non ha limiti.
Il suo mercato è in costante crescita.
Ma quanto è grande
questo mercato dall'animazione?
Vediamo, un attimo, l'animazione
in modo particolare dei lungometraggi.
Questi sono dati basati su lungometraggi
usciti negli Stati Uniti
e quindi con una diffusione
e una distribuzione mondiale.
Qui vedete negli ultimi 30 anni,
lo sviluppo del mercato dell'animazione.
In grigio c'è quello che rappresenta
il budget e il ritorno,
gli introiti dei grandi film,
dei grandi studi, cioè con molto budget,
i film commerciali, quelli che
andate solitamente a vedere al cinema
con i vostri figli e i vostri nipoti.
E in rosso, in basso, molto in basso,
come vedete, i film indipendenti,
che hanno dei budget limitatissimi
rispetto a quelli commerciali, purtroppo.
Possiamo anche vedere, poi,
l'enorme differenza
che c'è nell'animazione al minuto.
Queste sono le spese al minuto,
per ogni film di animazione.
In media, un film commerciale raggiunge
il milione, milione e mezzo al minuto.
Mentre i film indipendenti, purtroppo,
hanno solamente poche decine
di migliaia di dollari a disposizione
per minuto.
Contate che il business dell'animazione
ha raggiunto, l'anno scorso,
quasi i sette miliardi di dollari.
È in costante crescita.
E parlo solamente di lungometraggi,
non parliamo nemmeno di televisione.
E poi, un altro aspetto molto importante
per il nostro business è la distribuzione.
Perché se non si hanno sale
quando escono i film
durante il primo weekend,
nessuno andrà a vedere i nostri film,
ovviamente.
I film commerciali hanno, di solito,
a disposizione 2500 - 3000 sale in media,
con dei picchi di quasi 5000,
a seconda degli studi, chiaramente.
Come vedete sotto in rosso,
devo dire la verità,
ho dovuto aumentare il rosso
perché se no non lo vedevate,
per i film indipendenti
sono una manciata di sale.
Vi assicuro, l'anno scorso
sono andata a vedere un bellissimo film
di animazione indipendente,
e le scelte erano
Los Angeles e New York,
una sala, un giorno.
Purtroppo.
Da questi dati
penso che capiate le potenzialità
di un lungometraggio di animazione.
Ogni anno,
centinaia di artisti e di registi
riescono a fare e produrre
i loro cortometraggi
e spessissimo trattano temi forti,
importanti, culturalmente diversi.
Ma, purtroppo, sono destinati
solamente ai festival,
per cui con un'audience di nicchia,
raggiungono poche persone.
Alcuni riescono a fare
anche dei lungometraggi,
ma poi, come avete visto,
non hanno distribuzione.
E allora cosa possiamo fare
per cambiare le cose?
Non ci resta che fare una rivoluzione.
La rivoluzione del FARE:
Fidati, Agisci, Rischia, Esplora.
Ma questa rivoluzione
non può partire solo da noi,
dagli addetti ai lavori,
dagli artisti, dagli animatori.
Deve partire da tutti noi!
Io spero che, nel futuro,
i grossi studi di animazione
decidano di investire anche in film
che sono socialmente diversi,
con temi impegnati.
Quale miglior mezzo
se non l'animazione,
per portare ai nostri figli
storie diverse,
che li arricchiscano,
che possano eliminare
queste barriere culturali,
avvicinarci tutti un pochino di più
e forse sperare, insieme,
in un mondo migliore.
Se siete un produttore
e vedete una storia fantastica
che vi entusiasma,
non pensate subito
a quanto farà ai botteghini.
Seguite il vostro cuore,
datele una possibilità.
Se siete un distributore,
offrite a questi film delle sale.
Abbiate fiducia nel vostro pubblico.
Roma non è stata creata in un giorno,
tutte le cose hanno bisogno di tempo,
non solo per essere fatte,
ma anche per essere create.
E soprattutto, la cosa più importante,
se siete genitori, come lo sono io,
scegliete film di animazione
con la stessa cura
con cui scegliete
il cibo buono per i vostri figli,
e se non lo trovate a disposizione,
richiedetene, fatevi sentire.
Vi assicuro che la forza è con voi
e siete voi che decidete.
Dovete farvi sentire dai distributori,
dai produttori, dai grandi studi,
e tutti insieme potete cambiare le cose.
Potete partecipare a creare
un mondo migliore.
Come diceva Walt Disney:
"L'unico modo per riuscire a cambiare
le cose è smettere di parlare e agire".
Grazie!
(Applausi)